Trump was right that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
at the end of a week like this with so
many of the world's events having turned
against us we once again arrive at the
conclusion that yes Trump was right
now remember from the very first months
of his presidency he challenged the
scaled old status quo you know that
status quo where America carried the
Lion's Share of the security burden for
Europe
NATO members must finally contribute
their fair share and meet
their financial obligations if NATO
countries made their full and complete
contributions the NATO would be even
stronger than it is today
now he made it clear that the days were
over when the United Nations and other
foreign countries could just run
roughshod over America's interests we
are only going to give foreign aid to
those who respect us
and frankly are our friends
and we expect
other countries to pay their fair share
for
the cost of their defense
the United States is committed to making
the United Nations
more effective
and accountable
his Common Sense message seemed kind of
subdue there didn't he but it infuriated
our sanctimonious scribblers to no end
Trump's takedown of their sacred cow the
rules-based international order
that thing wasn't just wrong the order
what he said about it was dangerous
Donald Trump is needlessly recklessly
and mindlessly doing right now to
destroy the underpinnings of the
american-led international order they
chose to walk away for many of the
institutions that have really formed or
informed American foreign policy now for
nearly three quarters of a century the
greatest threat to the liberal
International order right now is surely
the Trump Administration no free the
greatest threat to the order was and is
the globalist status quo
even Henry Kissinger understood this
yeah the man most responsible for
America's opening to China in the 1970s
he saw the growing threat of Beijing and
had how it becomes so dangerous under
President XI and advised Trump in a
series of meetings on ways to box out
China by establishing closer ties to
Russia
the potential strategy would use closer
relationships with Russia along with
other countries in the region to box in
China's growing power and influence
while Trump agreed with Kissinger's
points and before the phony Mueller
investigation began he would have
followed a strategy designed to draw
Moscow closer to prevent China from
forging a new alliance with them
during the Cold War U.S foreign policy
was aimed at keeping Russia and China
apart after two years of Biden they've
never been closer after she wrapped up
his visit in Moscow this week Putin and
he didn't just toast a budding Alliance
they said their partnership will reshape
the future
well if we continue on the Biden path
that is exactly what's going to happen
America will grow weaker and less
independent with each passing year as
China grows more powerful
now Germany and much of Europe already
seems quite comfortable with Russia or
China in the driver's seat another thing
Trump called
Germany will become totally dependent
on Russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
here in the Western Hemisphere we are
committed
to maintaining our independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
and now China is on the Move everywhere
including in our own hemisphere earlier
this month Honduran president yamara
Castro announced that his country will
establish diplomatic ties with China
effectively ending their relationship
with Taiwan
with Trump gone China's gaining
influence and power not just to the
South though but to the north as well in
Canada which is one of our closest
allies and trading partners as you know
the newspaper Globe and Mail reported
last month that China preferred to see
Trudeau's liberals reelected in the 2021
election and worked to defeat
conservative politicians considered
unfriendly to Beijing
China has been known of course to prefer
a certain type of candidate in Western
countries the weak Biden type
in fact in 2020 U.S Intel sources warned
that China was deeply opposed to Trump's
re-election
gee I wonder why
and as America has become economically
weaker Trudeau has become less willing
to take a tough stand against China on
almost any issue including that issue of
election interference
but we didn't expect Biden in Canada
today to announce a new immigration
impact he did not raise any of these
issues with China and certainly didn't
want to offend pretty boy Justin
Biden's busy overseeing our military as
it gets bullied out of the South China
Sea
China's defense Ministry said today that
China drove away the U.S Navy destroyer
the USS Milius after it entered
territorial Waters of China's
now this is exceedingly dangerous
on top of all the other little just a
small matter of a potential nuclear war
if things go sideways in Ukraine
and then Biden's presided over more
American losses in the Middle East an
American contractor was killed and five
American troops injured when an Iranian
drone struck an American base in Syria
yeah you probably forgot we actually
have troops there
why are those 900 troops still on the
ground in Syria I can tell you for
certain they are not providing any
benefit to the United States and the
claim that the generals making here that
they are there for the enduring defeat
of Isis look that is nonsense now in
retaliation supposedly at Biden's direct
direction we launched counter-strikes on
sites in eastern Syria
well after Iranian back forces ignited
this latest exchange the Pentagon went
out of its way today to reassure the
global community that it didn't seek any
conflict with Iran but that it seeks
only stability in the region well it's a
little late for that
did Americans though vote for any of
these escalations
and are we getting anything out of the
rules-based international order that we
were told is so vital to American
interests well of course not
and this is something else Trump called
out
we're spending tremendous amounts of
money for decades on policing the world
and that shouldn't be our priority we
want to police ourselves and we want to
rebuild our country we are ending the
era
of endless Wars it is not the duty of
U.S troops to solve ancient conflicts
and Far Away lands
that many people have never even heard
of
well of course Biden's Pentagon does
believe that America has a World Police
role this is why in part we're fighting
that proxy war in Ukraine and wasting
energy condemning what Uganda this week
for I guess it's anti-sodomy laws
in the end this is why realism in
America First nationalism must come to
define the Republican party going
forward
the idea that somehow the U.S is going
to be safer and more stable if it abides
by these so-called Global Norms this has
always been Fantasyland stuff
Trump knew this instinctively
and the angle frankly is thrilled that
this idea of a so-called rules-based
International order is collapsing before
our eyes
that's in America's best interest
the Republican party though will only
succeed if it Embraces this vision
we know Trump will
but who else and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else